[Musique]
antoine enfin à jean paul vous avez
présenté les césar en 1996 97 98 99
votre mission si toutefois vous
l'acceptez c'est d'y retourner pardon
mais vous avez bien ici toutefois c'est
une formule antoine et c'est à dire
c'est à dire que c'est un ordre à ses 6
et un autre toujours si vous ou l'un de
vos otages ont été capturés ou tués
l'académie nierait avoir eu connaissance
de vos agissements je peux vous poser
une petite question avant que vous
déclenchez le bouzin comment avez vous
eu accès à ma plomberie cette vidéo
s'autodétruira 25 secondes dix neuf au
bo vous avez dit cinq secondes à peine à
cinq
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
retour chez vous
[Musique]
c'est la nouvelle qui bouleverse le
monde du septième art donc antoine de
caunes qui présentera la 47e cérémonie
des césar sur canal+ antoine antoine de
caunes sera pour la dixième fois maître
de cérémonie a été que cette année c'est
un montois
vraiment de michael
wood jean-stéphane
neutralisé mois de caunes on va leur
montrer client n a qu à thème bien
joseph
neutralisé mois de caunes on va leur
montrer qu'ils à reda kateb bien sauf
vous fait quoi là
allez-y
merci reda du coude va présenter les
césar pour la dixième fois tu me le
quart chez les prisons
[Musique]
nous avons prises
oui excusez moi te déranger c'est quoi
déjà le code
ta gueule ah oui merci ta gueule
un bar où je cherche la bière bon je
vous laisse conclure
[Musique]
allez zou budget
bonjour si c'est par où l'olympia vous
faites deux cent pas sur le chemin et je
vais vers la forêt non bah on fait deux
cents passant le chemin de cent pas sur
le chemin voilà et je vais pas faire un
nom
pour ce rappel
[Musique]
avec moi
et le caf ya des japonais remet partout
dans une manière de filtre
et vous êtes sûr que c'est une bonne loi
la pierre comme ça va je peux poser de
questions wengen ok ok après jour et
très adroites évidemment patriotes à
lescar devant un hôpital manier vous et
banias et valérie qu'est ce qu'il fait
ce n'est qu'après le moyeu fixe comme ça
il a pris cher à de regarder ça fait
un salut catherine benoit ça tombe bien
ça te dirait de venir remettre un césar
cette année
c'est dommage ça va être une bonne
cérémonie
c'est sûr pour moi vous savez la
situation change d'avis
qu'est ce qu'il fout enceinte ou celui
[Musique]
on attendait
ça veut dire quoi c'est un signe de dieu
l'avertissement quelque chose de
terrible
[Musique]
et sur quoi elle touche hip hop
c'est l'heure
[Musique]
le bras
à
tu vas faire battre
je saute
oui
revenue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
bonsoir